hey welcome to your new project camp
update it's early in the morning
because we're going to go to a cork
factory where they're going to harvest
the cork in a farm and and the factory
already going to produce it into
useful things so we're going to see how
the process works should be exciting
[Music]
[Music]
so yeah
like dave said before it's six in the
morning so the streets are still empty
the landscape is beautiful covered in
thick fog
and the early sun just started to reach
out her first golden sunbeams
we are making our way in dave's shaky
van on the highway hello
a two and a half hours drive is waiting
for us
first stop is the cork factory called
safarka
located somewhere in the countryside
between project camp and lisbon
there we're gonna meet charles
he runs a company called corklink who is
a local supplier for a variety of cork
products
he was kind enough to invite us for a
tour around the cork tree farms and the
factory
we met him on the parking place of the
factory jumped in his car because it's a
bit faster and continue further south to
the cork tree fields
so
let's see what is waiting there for us
[Music]
[Music]
looks like you're in africa
there's the lions giraffes
[Music]
so dave where are we now
so we're currently at a
cork field with a lot of pork
trees and we're gonna see
how they're gonna get harvest how it
works
uh
yeah what a day of a car cork harvester
why is it shaking so much uh we're in
the back of a pickup truck because uh
well hearts two axles
all right so we're now at the cork
harvest place here we have charles he's
going to give us a little bit of a tour
about how the harvesting process works
well um
we're in
southern portugal here where most of the
court trees grow
in portugal
and during the summer months
the whole of the cork forest in portugal
have their bark stripped
the guys we can see working here
travel around the central and southern
portugal
taking the bark off the trees in teams
so you can see that the the technique
they use is they have an extremely sharp
axe
and they bash at the tree to just cut
the bark and they have to hit the bark
with just the right amount of strength
so that the bark gets cracked open but
they don't damage the membrane
that's inside the bark covering the tree
because if you damage that membrane then
the tree can die so these guys it looks
like they're just smacking away at the
tree but actually it's a finely judged
amount of force that they're using to
hit the trees that the bark will fall
off naturally
and funnily enough each of these guys
their axe is their own
personal axe and they treat it like a
their pride and joy it's like a concert
violinist with their violin they won't
let anyone else touch their axe and they
sharpen it all day long and it has just
the right weight for them so they know
exactly how hard to whack the tree when
they're taking the cork off
so the cork can only be removed every
nine years
because otherwise you don't have enough
thickness in the cork to be able to use
it to making wine corks
and the joy of cork is that
taking this bark off the tree does no
damage at all to it
and the cork will grow back so nine
years later you can harvest the cork
again
and in fact some of these trees around
here are 200 years old and they've been
harvested every nine years
for for 200 years
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
nothing happens quickly in court forests
so um a young tree like this one here
which is maybe um four or five years old
is not ready to give up um quality cork
um until it's 15 or 20 years old
so
the first first
seven or eight years the court trees
just left to grow
and then afterwards you can see this
tree here
this has been harvested once so it's had
its had its first harvest and this is
the regrowth you can see the original
cork is here which hasn't been harvested
at all so this is the regrowth here
the first harvest of the cork is called
virgin cork and it's extremely resinous
and you can't use it to make wine corks
so that's generally used to make
expanded cork
the second harvest is generally a
reasonable quality cork but it's not the
best quality the best quality comes in
the third fourth fifth harvest and some
of these trees around here are 200 years
old and they can give some fabulous
quality cork which is used
for
natural wine court to the best quality
of these amazing cork forests in
portugal
are actually also a fabulous carbon sink
because these trees they'll grow for 200
years or more
and whilst with other wood products you
have to cut the tree down and that ends
its purpose of absorbing carbon
these court trees carry on going forever
so you're just removing the bark and
meanwhile the tree every year for its
entire lifespan is sucking carbon out
carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere
and all that's left over is the cork
bark which is processed into cork to
make a biodegradable product
so it's really the perfect sustainable
product
for the
21st century and beyond
so the cork they harvested is put on
this truck which goes to the factory and
in the factory gonna process it into
things we're gonna granulate it chop it
so we're gonna now have a look at the
factory to see how it's being processed
[Music]
so after the harvest we went to a
factory where they process it turns out
there are three different ways to
process the cork natural congemerated
and expanded cork
here charles explains the difference
using the classic wine stopper as an
example
so you saw in the forest that we um took
off those big planks of cork off the
trees
well that's the first step into making
natural wine corks so these those big
planks we saw in the forest are now cut
up into strips um so this would be the
outside of the tree and here would be
the inside of the tree then to make a
natural wine court which is the um the
most premium kind of wine cork you
literally have a punch
and it punches through the cork
and pushes the cork out the other side
and at the end of it you have a natural
cork
so natural corks are the most prized
kind of corks and you see a very a very
premium
wine caulk looks like this with almost
no imperfections on the surface of it
so to get really good quality wine corks
you need to have really good quality
cork once you've made the wine corks you
have all this leftover cork
what happens to this it gets granulated
turned into granules and then those
granules can be glued together to make
um either to make boards like this one
which you see for flooring or for notice
boards or they can be made into
agglomerated wine corks
so an agglomerated wine cork is much
more uniform than a natural wine cork
but of course it isn't 100 natural
because the granules have to be glued
together to make agglomerated cork
what's left after all of that cork has
been used for agglomerated cork and
natural cork
is
rotten bits of cork which no one really
wants so for example the branches of the
trees which have been trimmed like this
one
and this is what we've come to see today
is how all this waste cork which can't
be used for anything else how it can be
turned into an amazing insulation
material which is expanded cork and then
this bark
can then be
agglomerated
using a different process to make
expanded cork
and one of the key differences about
this expanded cork is that unlike
the agglomerated cork here
the expanded cork is made in a different
way the um resin which is present in the
cork
uh branches itself
is used to bind the expanded cork
granules
together so this is 100
natural product just like natural corks
are so you would say
this thing is cool 100 natural straight
from the bark yeah this one lasts
because you need glue it's cool that is
leftover but you need glue to put it
together and this thing is also 100
natural because the resin in the cork
tree
is held together exactly right and
what's amazing about this whole process
is that from the bark that comes off the
tree
not one
grain is wasted it can all be used in
different ways and in fact the dust
that's produced when you're doing this
process is then used to make energy for
the factories to be able to
treat the cork itself so it's a
completely circular process
so we're gonna have a look at factory
let's go
here you can see the factory and this
one they make expanded cork
the one that is granulated but processed
100 natural because the resin in the
tree is the glue the factory looks
peaceful from up here
however the factory is loud shredders
steam compressed air flowing around you
can't hear anything on camera so we got
a tour from the boss very nice guy and
i'll narrate the process for you once we
get inside so let's start at the
beginning of making expanded cork the
raw material they have mountains of cork
[Music]
so here we are at an expanded cork
factory uh expanded cork is one of the
most amazing insulation materials i've
ever come across 100 natural and a
fantastic insulator and what's one of
the really great things about it is we
use for expanded cork the really rough
bits of cork that no one else wants to
use so this cork i've got in my hand
here and this massive pile you can see
behind me is scraps of cork that
essentially no one else wants to use and
here at the factory we're going to see
how we're going to take this cork
granulate it sort it so we get the best
bits that we need to make the insulation
expanded cork board and then make it
into big blocks
which can then be cut into sheets of
expanded cork to insulate your home or
whatever else needs insulating so let's
go and visit the factory
so first step is to filter out the piles
of pork because all the cork is left
over and mixed with sand and stones
but also wood from the cork tree itself
can still be stuck on the bark so they
throw it into big machines that shake it
and get the rough dirt out and then the
shredder that chops it into small
granules
they're transported on screws and
conveyor belts all with different
systems to filter out unwanted materials
at this point it's a mix of different
granule sizes of cork so they also
separate them
the small ones can be used for expanding
and will be used for biomass the large
ones will go back in the system to shred
again and the medium size continues the
process
this is what the granules look like
after sorting and shredding
then they go into this beast the boiler
here they use the biomass leftover from
before to heat it up and produce steam
from water
you mentioned that the boiler was
installed in the 70s and still running
very basic and durable machine
and the room down here is fired up every
morning at seven until midnight it's a
thousand degrees in there yeah we didn't
go in
then it goes to the next step the core
of the process the actual pressing
here the cork granules go into a big
metal mold
in this case the shape of a big
rectangular block once the mold is full
they close it heat it up and with steam
and heat the cork expands and the resin
comes out
meanwhile it's pressed together with a
big hydraulic press
the process of filling the mold heating
it up and taking it out is about 20
minutes
and once it comes out the block have a
deep brown color because of the heat
the cork itself doesn't burn but just
turns dark but inside these blocks you
can actually see a few little red
glowing things these are little pieces
of wood that didn't manage to filter out
and they did burn and turn into charcoal
but the amount of wood is minimal so
it's not really a problem and from there
the block is cut it open so it can cool
down faster
and water is sprinkled on top
at this point you have a solid block of
expanded cork naturally glued together
with just heat and pressure
these blocks will rest outside for a few
weeks so to get rid of all the tension
inside and then to the final step
cutting
here the blocks are brought in and cut
to size
the blocks feel solid but are
lightweight
the popular purpose for them is
insulation since it has a high r value
but it also has a few other cool
properties as for instance you saw
before the wood burnt and the cork
doesn't so it's very fire resistant
and it's 100 natural material which is
very unique for an insulator
some people use it between walls roofs
floors or even directly on the outside
the application defines the thickness
you need thinner for walls and thicker
for the roofs
so this is the end result sheets of
expanded cork you can have them in
different sizes and thicknesses
and we want to use this for our roon as
an insulation material
so we need to figure out what's the size
we want what's the thickness so we need
to do some calculations and measurements
but uh yeah we're going to see more
about that later on
[Music]
alright so that was it for this video if
you really want to see the next one for
next week make sure to subscribe on
patreon if not to see us here next week
same channel same time
thanks for watching
[Music]
you